mon second
run
nous y habitent le village de kanji
soupe au nunavik
aujourd'hui elle est à 1600 km de chez
elle dans un appartement d'ottawa
elle prépare un véritable festin emporté
dans ses bagages
du caribou de l'omble chevalier du pilou
cas du narval
c'est pour faire plaisir à son fils brad
ciac qui s'ennuient de la maison
mais surtout pour faire vivre à notre
équipe une immersion culinaire
[Musique]
animaux
faire face
si lou sicret se trouve si loin de chez
elle c'est le partage avec nous les
secrets de ses traditions c'est parce
qu'elle est en mission contre des
polluants qu'on dit éternel des produits
chimiques quasi indestructible qui
voyage jusqu'au pôle et se concentre
dans la nourriture traditionnelle des
inuits
il est inerte et
avoir plus de force aux
sprinteurs camille causse
la première fois que nous rencontrons
l'oci gré c'est à montréal en décembre
2021 avec le scientifique mélanie lemire
elle se prépare à participer à une
conférence internationale
les deux femmes veulent alerter la
population mondiale les inouk ont joué
un rôle prépondérant dans la lutte
contre les contaminants environnementaux
que ça soit pour les bpc pour le mercure
est maintenant pour les pma aise les pf
as c'est une grande famille de composés
chimiques qu'on appelle aussi les
perfluorés
à cause de la forte liaison entre leurs
attentes de fluor et carbone ces
molécules sont extrêmement stable elle
ne se décrète pas dans la nature elles
s'accumulent dans l'environnement et
dans le corps humain
[Musique]
le pf as ont des propriétés anti tâches
et anti adhésive qui les rendent très
populaire
on les retrouve pratiquement partout
certains articles de cuisine comme les
poêles anti-adhésives sur les tapis ou
des meubles même dans des emballages
alimentaires donc par exemple les petits
emballages de fritz qui ont leurs
progrès ce même site et frites sont
encore graisseuse c'est parce que il ya
probablement des composés perfluorés
c'est des molécules extrêmement
performante qui repoussent l'eau et la
grèce on en retrouvera même dans
certains types de maquillage ce n'est
pas le maquillage par exemple qui
résiste à l'eau on en retrouve aussi où
on en retrouvait dans le fameux gore-tex
les matériaux technics performant pour
aller faire du plein air
mélanie le meilleur et spécialiste en
médecine sociale et préventive à
l'université laval
elle étudie comment les changements
environnementaux affecte la santé des
inuits vu la plupart des molécules
chimiques comme les vieux bpc par
exemple vont voyager au pôle puis
ensuite ceux déposés et s'accumuler dans
les différentes chaînes alimentaires que
ce soit la chaîne marine ou la chaîne
terrestre
les animaux qui se trouve au sommet de
la chaîne alimentaire sont les plus
contaminées dans la mer ce sont les
mammifères marins comme le béluga et le
narval dans le cadre d'une étude publiée
en 2020 mélanie lemire a mesuré la
concentration de certains pfs dans le
centre de femmes enceintes ou nunavik
leur expulsion est pratiquement le
double en comparaison avec des femmes du
même âge dans la population canadienne
en général mais aussi que ce qu'on
appelle les composés perfluorés à longue
chaîne des jeunes en particulier l'udc
s'appelle les pfnl aller 6 fois plus
élevés que sorte qu'on retrouve dans le
sud donc il ya là une grande injustice
environnementale
[Musique]
et
copines
d'où ses craies et mélanie lemire
collabore avec une délégation canadienne
pour convaincre les pays membres de la
convention de stockholm de bannir les
pieds face
la convention de stockholm c'est un
accord international qui vise à
interdire ou à limiter l'usagé substance
particulièrement nocive pour la planète
oui mais tout comme venus des
internationaux communes et des we need
[Musique]
you need to be nice camille causse
bernard essentials
fille nina ricci
n'gaous practice in
living in a green
it right
les pfs ne date pas d'hier l'un des tout
premiers membres de la famille le pf hoa
a été créée par des chimistes dans les
années 1940 on est mort le bioparc
et société 3m et dupont en ont aussitôt
fabriquer des quantités phénoménales
il servait entre autres à fabriquer le
revêtement antiadhésif téflon
une usine de du pont situé à part que ce
bug en virginie occidentale s'est
retrouvé au coeur d'une poursuite
judiciaire
l'afer a révélé à quel point le ps fois
était nocif pour la santé
l'histoire commence au début des années
1980 quand dupont achète un bout de
terrain d'un fermier pour racheter des
résidus qu'il dit inoffensifs après
quelques années le fermier se rendre
compte que les petits ruisseaux passe à
côté de chez eux commencent à changer de
couleur comment savoir de la moss puis
les vaches quel s abreuver au ruisseau
tombé malade ou mourir la saga
judiciaire a duré des décennies
la cour a nommé au comité de
scientifiques indépendants
ils ont évalué la santé de 70000
personnes vivant autour de l' usine puis
son disque aussi qu'il y avait un lien
probable entre l'exposition aux pères
fois et diverses mesures de santé dont
une augmentation du risque de que
l'étude sérieuse n'est pas attention
pendant la grossesse si une augmentation
du risque de maladies thyroïdiennes du
parc à l'estival amy est aussi une
augmentation nouveau disque du cancer du
rein et du testicule
depuis l' agence américaine de
protection de l'environnement a fixé une
limite pour la concentration de payer
fois dans l'eau potable
santé canada a aussi adopté des lignes
directrices
le problème c'est que les chimistes ont
créé des milliers d'autres molécules
appartenant à la même famille de
nouveaux pfs qui pour la très grande
majorité ne sont pas réglementés
même à de faibles concentrations
il semble causer des problèmes pour la
santé par exemple il affaiblirait le
système immunitaire
marc-andré verner et professeur à
l'école de santé publique de
l'université de montréal la toxicité dpf
as c'est sa spécialité
les données qu'on a prouvé ça n'a pas
beaucoup mais ce qu'on voit c'est qu'ils
semblent avoir
plus d'effets graves liés des infections
acavite chez les gens qui ont
déconcentré son père fasse plus élevée
dans l'ars
sonnex et six matches
et
ne compte pas cesser de manger la
nourriture traditionnelle inuite
en se battant pour préserver ses
traditions tous y luttent pour la santé
de tous les canadiens
même si le canada n'a jamais produit de
pfs nous sommes tous exposés à
différents degrés
malheureusement on importe une grande
porte partie de nos biens de
consommation donc ils grande partie
échappe à la législation canadienne
parce que c'est très difficile de savoir
la composition chimique des produits
qu'on importe
dans le sud du canada les pfs se
concentrent dans les sites
d'enfouissement
on les retrouve aussi sur le terrain des
aéroports et des bases militaires où
l'on utilise des mousses à base de pfs
pour s'entraîner à éteindre des feux de
pétrole
nous avons prélevé un échantillon d'eau
potable de l'aqueduc de la ville de
montréal
nous l'avons emporté à sébastien sauvé
professeur de chimie à l'université de
montréal la mise au point le des
laboratoires les plus sophistiqués au
monde pour mesurer les pf as dans
l'environnement donc y en a c'est clair
dans à peu près tous les échantillons
d'eau potable on en trouve même dans
l'eau embouteillée
au cours des dernières années sébastien
sauvé a mesuré les pf as dont l'eau
potable de près de 400 municipalités du
québec dans pratiquement tous les
échantillons et à trouver des pfs quand
notre propre échantillons il a détecté
des traces de 19 molécules de la famille
des pfs
les échantillons d'eau potable qui ont
été produites à même le fleuve saint
laurent sont habituellement plus élevé à
peu près le double que les autres est
bon qu'on attribue vraiment un à charge
urbaine tout le long du fleuve saint
laurent puis des grains akiyo que
beaucoup d'usinés beaucoup de villes il
ya beaucoup de sources de perf le riz
les systèmes de traitement de l'eau
potable n'arrive pas à enlever les pfs
toutes ces propriétés qu'on aime buxy
anti salissures et etc elles font aussi
que ces mêmes propriétés la fonction
difficile de les détruire par une
attaque chimique parce que la molécule
et stade et sont aussi difficiles à
retenir avec le charbon avec une usine
ou autre chose les concentrations de pfs
trouvé par sébastien sauvé sont en
dessous des recommandations actuelles
pour l'eau potable
mais au fur et à mesure que les
recherches progressent les normes
deviennent de plus en plus strictes
le plus simple serait de bannir les pf
as à la source
ou sucrées et mélanie lemire n'ont pas
pu partir pour genève où se tenait la
réunion de la convention de stockholm
l'aco vide compromis leur blanc elles
ont fait leur présentation à partir d'un
appartement loué pour l'occasion à
montréal
leur démarche a été couronnée de succès
grâce à la délégation canadienne
plusieurs polluants de la famille des
pfs pour être soumis à une évaluation
pour éventuellement être inscrit à la
convention de stockholm les
scientifiques engagés dans cette
bataille rêve déjà d'aller plus loin
l'industriel de plusieurs molécules de
remplacement dans sa poche arrière qui
est prêt à ressortir des convois ban est
un des produits
pour les experts en santé publique
il ne faut pas bannir les molécules une
à une c'est toute la famille dpf as
qu'il faut contrôler le sucre et compte
participer à la prochaine rencontre de
la convention de stockholm l'automne
prochain à rome
[Musique]
on est affecté à sanaa taiana faute et
sa facture
à